at the start of her monologue as the
headliner of the White House
Correspondents Association dinner
Michelle wolf a comedian neither myself
nor anyone on my staff had ever heard of
may plain the direction she was headed
in good evening here we are the White
House Correspondents Dinner like a porn
star says when she's about to have sex
with the Trump let's get this over with
yeah this is you're getting tonight
Ellie she had a really good voice well
they got much more of it though the
president wasn't in attendance press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
Kellyanne Conway and others from the
White House were at the dinner this was
sold by the way as an evening to
celebrate the First Amendment that's
nice but of all the comedians the
Correspondents Association could have
hired they turned to the obscure
Michelle wolf Trump pink yarn sales are
through the roof after Trump got elected
women started knitting those tats
when I first saw him I was like visible
I guess mine just has a lot more yarn on
it
should have done more research before
you got me to do this uh-huh that's an
understatement
well the choice of an aspirational
comedian like wolf with one HBO special
I guess in a few writing gigs to her
credit tells us a lot about the
Correspondents Association because some
of those who cover the White House let's
face it we know it are brimming with
hatred of this president and all that he
represents let's face it he embarrassed
them with his electoral victory and he
continues to prove them wrong
day after day and he ends up revealing
them for who they really are and I have
to say guys when you see when you see
the faces of the crowd at the
Correspondents Dinner when they were
like cutting away from the c-span
coverage it was like I was thinking wait
a second can we just have a full screen
and freeze it there because we need to
see the exact no no we need to see the
exact facial expressions on the
reporters who were laughing at the
particular times which we're about to
highlight and they come when you compare
what she was saying to what happened
when the president was speaking in
Michigan Wow
by the way is this better than that
phony Washington White House
Correspondents
I could be up there tonight smiling like
I love weather hitting you shot after
shot these people they ate your guts
well for this in other statements like
it the press will forever despise Trump
and unlike other Republican presidents
who ran to the nearest corner and crowd
sure even apologized when the media
attacked what is Trump do he returns
fire by choosing wolf as their avatar
the DC media elites have confirmed their
bias for anyone who wanted to give them
even the slightest benefit of the doubt
and boy was I glad my kids and I weren't
watching
I know people really want me to go after
Trump tonight but I think we should give
the president credit when he deserves it
like he pulled out of the Paris
agreement and I think he should get
credit for that because he said he was
gonna pull out and then he did and
that's a refreshing quality in a man
people say romance is dead my fence is
what happens when Anderson Cooper isn't
gay
Mike Pence is also very anti choice
he thinks abortion is murder which first
of all don't knock it till you try it
and when you do try it really knock it
you know you gotta get that baby out of
there
tasteless aggressively unfunny and it
was frankly sad for her I thought about
that a while after I was disgusted and
it of course I was insulting to half the
country who believes in protecting
innocent life
the Debbie wasserman-schultz
doppelganger in between dropping f-bombs
attacks sarah huckabee sanders looks who
of course was seated at the head table
with her
I actually really like Sarah I think
she's very resourceful
like she burns facts and then she uses
that Ash to create a perfect smoky eye
now imagine if this were someone let's
say a few years back attacking Susan
Rice or Valerie Jarrett or Samantha
powers or any adult child of a
Democratic president the fact that no
one heckled her that's like a in the
tradition of great comedy heckling back
and that so few walked out during wolf's
twenty minute rant it's frankly
astounding this after the meet to
movement conservatives and even some
reasonable liberals we got to give it to
them we were stunned by the audacity of
what they saw when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders was being made fun of I
everybody felt pain for her she felt
pain and it really bothered me if you
say well this year we want a tone of
civility and we want to try and lower
the temperature because the you know
nation's being ripped asunder and let's
try and do it a little differently
tonight you could add that conversation
the idea is to have a truce and let it
go but the remarks went way over the
line I think everyone agrees to that now
Michelle wolf herself finally responded
to the controversy on NPR today I'm
honestly I wouldn't change a single word
that I said I'm very happy with what I
said um and I'm glad I stuck to my guns
of course she's happy because she's just
another warrior
princess in the resistance the White
House Correspondents Association issued
this lame statement amid the wolf
fallout
last night's program was meant to offer
a unifying message about our common
commitment to a vigorous and Free Press
and while honoring civility great
reporting and scholarship winners not to
divide people
unfortunately the entertainer's
monologue was not in the spirit of that
mission civility a celebration of the
Free Press the White House
Correspondents Association has failed on
both counts had a conservative said the
things that wolf said about a democratic
administration they would be roadkill by
now that never work again White House
Correspondents President Margaret talev
sought to defuse the wolf controversy
over the weekend I hope that everyone
can remember that comedy is meant to be
provocative and it doesn't always hit
the mark and sometimes it hits the mark
for some people and not for other people
well provocative sure but not a verbal
assault that would never be tolerated if
not directed at conservatives you want
to know provocative Don Rickles
mr. warrants at Reagan's second
inaugural good evening mr. president
nice to see you sir and your lovely wife
Nancy it's a big treat for me to fly all
the way from California to be here for
this kind of money
and Billy Graham nice to see you sir
this hand is bothering me is this too
fast Ronny
he's sitting there looking at the
program where does he say he makes fun
of me where does it say that it's only a
junk mrs. Reagan
they've got real guns cutting but really
fun oh my gosh do we miss them wriggles
Rickles as a comedian who knew how to
push boundaries without crossing them
now compare that to ms Wolff which of
course brings me to the me to movement
it's probably the reason I'm here
they were like a woman's probably not
gonna in front of anyone right and to
that I say don't count your chickens ap
reporter Meg Canard captured it best
when she wrote on Twitter if the W HC D
dinner did anything tonight
it made the chasm between journalists
and those who don't trust us even wider
and those of us based in the red states
who work hard every day to prove our
objectivity we'll have to deal with it
this revealing episode has shown the
American people the hateful intolerance
of the press corps and those we trust to
cover the news canard is right it'll
take a long time to prove their
objectivity after this heinous display
and the fact that the Correspondents
Association is now talking about
reformatting their dinner rather than
just doing what they need to do which is
soul-searching about bias and the fact
that it exists just demonstrates the
problem anew
a filthy comedian and a tainted dinner
are symptoms of a deeper issue animus
animus against tradition against
conservatism against this president that
is the thing that taints their coverage
of this president in all our news on a
daily basis and that's the angle